we have this from cnr.com White House
reportedly wants to replace kamla Harris
acknowledging Biden is in Decline this
comes from the Intrepid work of James
O'Keefe who uh had this is this is one
of the most brutal undercover
investigations he's done in my opinion
but it is newsworthy it is important and
it is the fault of the the target of the
sting operation or whatever you want to
call it the
investigation okay so basically James
goes on a date I guess with a guy and
the guy clar K dressed as clerk K he
basically he puts on what he put on like
a vest and glasses he should have parted
his hair the opposite way just Parts it
the other am I crazy and thinking he
tweeted the other day like what if I
dyed my hair in more glasses and one
recognize something proba after probably
already I hope so so so look this is a
top White House cyber security official
speaking with James o'keef in Disguise
James was just wearing glasses in disg
dye his hair like his tweet these people
are not smart here's what's important no
this guy
says they've had discussions about
removing Kam Harris but they can't
because she's the first black
multiracial VP and she's next in line
something everyone on the right has
acknowledged they won't say publicly we
know they have already discussed it he's
also acknowledged B the signs of Biden's
decline are there but he's not been
clinically diagnosed with dementia and
this guy look I'm watching this video
from James and I feel real bad for him I
feel bad for this guy but I don't feel
bad enough to where I care because he
works in the executive office of the
White House these things that are being
said must be said to the American people
yeah and the only way we can learn about
the fears that the White House has with
their failing and ailing president is
when someone privately says it they
won't go public and say listen the
American people we're we're concerned
about this to be fair fine security
issues May freak people out a
functioning government and Country in my
opinion knowing that Joe Biden was
incapable
would remove him they would come out and
say we need him to step down 25th
amendment we're getting rid of him but
they don't want to because they don't
want to lose power in the end James
makes the best point you work in cyber
security for the White House and then he
takes his glasses off and goes why are
you having a meeting with James O'Keefe
and the guy's like oh yeah I've heard of
you and he's like you're just telling me
everything and I was like yeah I feel
bad in the sense that this guy thought
he was going on a date and he was just
going to have a good time and then
spilled all the beans I don't I don't
feel well no but I on a personal level
it's like you know some guy he's going
to have some wine with James you're
going on a date turns out you're being
set up like but here's the issue fun
here's here's a here's here's a question
when I was watching this with my
girlfriend and immediately she goes does
he have clearance and I was like oh man
not anymore right I bet he did and he's
saying yo you can't go out and tell a
random person from the White House
Office we've discussed having Tom Harris
be be replaced on the
ticket know that it's like they know
that it's James o'keef so they just use
it to plant false information I don't
think they're that smart you're giving
them too much the like there's a thing
like when like when they were promoting
the like Man of Steel they had Henry
Caville sit directly under a Superman
poster and nobody recognized him and I I
think people know James's name but not
everyone knows his his face I mean
because some of his work is done by
other undercover reporters and stuff
like that and James points out I mean
look they're they're working cyber
security they should know who James
O'Keefe is you would think well and if
they are working cyber security and if
he is prominent in cyber security it
would most likely be a top secret
security clearance that he has that he
just burned on camera in front of how
many views as that have now I mean
probably Millions at this point it was
trending takes off the glasses he's like
oh I remember you from that oligarchy
music video yeah it's got you sing car
one podcast it's got 9.3 million views
just on the original post so his
security clearance is burned at this
point I almost guarant I need to stress
guys look as I'm watching this we were
we having lunch um I had a chicken
Caesar salad blackened chicken it was
incredible by the way everyone agrees
and uh I just feel bad for this lonely
guy who met some dude probably on some
dating app and it was James O'Keefe the
whole time but what I love about this
I'm sorry I have to say it is the meme
where it was like if you are talking to
a beautiful woman it is James O'Keefe
yes if you work in Tech if you work for
Democratic organizations and the most
beautiful woman in the world is super
into you it's James O'Keefe this time
this time it was literally James oef I I
bet it's a super like that they get too
it's like not just a normal like but
they hit him with the super like the
star pops up and everything makes them
feel all giddy inside then they go on
the date and just get absolutely burned
on a national level I think this needs
to be stressed though my point as as
much as I felt bad James broke one of
the biggest stories of the year right
here with an someone who works in the
White House outright saying we have had
meetings about replacing K Harris on the
ticket yeah we are not going to but
they've acknowledge that she is
unpopular and can't win that is massive
massive uh scoop that James o'keef got
by doing this but there's the party of
unity and coming together yes it's just
crazy to me that the Democratic
president can't pull us off I mean this
is it's it's nice to have confirmation
for a thing I think everyone suspected
but really hopefully this is a video
that you play to anyone who's moderate
or left in your life and say this is
from your own camp this is someone who
actively supports Biden they work in his
White House and they're saying the VP
and president are afraid at best and
also no one likes this VP and also we
think he has dementia this is your
strong leadership for the nation right
now is this what you want I I feel like
you could but at the same time a lot of
these people are so disillusioned
they'll take like the Mark Cuban stance
of like you edit your videos like this
has to be edited deep fake it's AI
something along that's the frustrating
thing about Ai and like all the stuff is
that it just makes it easier for all
kinds of people to deny the truth and in
this case you know I think there are
people who would not trust James o'keef
just be out of personal bias right they
don't they don't trust anything he does
but the Biden Administration can't hide
the fact that they are in a rough
position I mean when we talk about
Biden's Health they delay releasing his
physical every year later and later and
I swear that doctor who signs it must
just be sort of like ly he's just
conducting it on himself he's just like
well he's holding the step last year
this was the thing like when the last
one came out there's a specific line
about Biden's gate and people will say
it's like a dementia Shuffle there's
there's a sign that this is this is
what's happening and uh he was like yes
his gate has stiffened but really not
that much and it's actually fine and
this is the thing that they do over and
over again like we acknowledge that you
might be seeing something but you're
insane for thinking it's actually a good
thing you're acting crazy he started
shuffling because the weight of the far
right extremists are just bearing him
down and how dare you question him I do
appreciate look like it's there's a a
bit of confirmation bias that I think
everybody has like the idea of pointing
out there's edits in this video that's
actually a good instinct to have for
everyone you should apply that same
logic to the people who make content
that you agree with as well you should
be looking for the uh where the video
starts where the video ends are there
Cuts in here is there something that's
being removed it's just it seems most
people can only seem to apply that when
they already disagree with the point
they're not willing to look critically
at the stuff they agree with in the same
way and I think that you open yourself
up to a lot more information if you're
willing to do that the other big scoop
here which may not applied to to today
but is very relevant is that he said I
had a meeting with Michelle Obama and
intern he said someone asked her what he
said when I was an intern someone asked
her will you ever run for office and she
said no emphatically no I've seen all
the ish my husband has uh has had to do
go through and it does not interest me
so many people have pointed out Michelle
Obama does not want to
run he said Biden will be the nominee K
Harris will be the VP on the ticket and
that's what they will play and it's just
kind of like maybe this guy did know who
James was the whole time and they're
baiting him because yo Biden can't win I
understand that we were saying this in
2020 so I will gladly say knock on wood
you never know what's going to happen
but at the time Biden actually was
winning in the polls and we were in
disbelief the polls could be right and I
think we're mostly correct the polls
were not right and due to very clever
what we call it Shadow campaigning is
what time magazine called it Joe Biden
wins the presidency as how I'll describe
it Shadow K I think right now you know
when Ian is talking about how his
parents are like man this migrant crisis
is crazy I'm like Biden's losing the
normies how are they going to maintain
the facade well I even have like what I
would consider normies within my family
my extended family whenever I'm you know
around they're asking me about this
because they're seeing seeing some of my
reporting or they're seeing what's going
on with the border and that's always
what they want to talk about is the
Border because that's what they find the
most interest in and you know they talk
about you know how are taxpaying dollars
going towards this and it genuinely
makes them mad so and I see this happen
over and over again whenever at family
events and I'm like okay so people that
usually don't pay attention to politics
or usually don't even follow my work
within my family are now noticing you
know so the noticing is high nowadays I
would say I think part of it is that
people feel the economic pressure I mean
they no one thinks Biden has done a good
job on the economy if if you talk to
normal people things are not are tough
and so to hear on top of that that not
only do we send money abroad but also
when we spend money domestically it's
actually on people who are not here
legally it must be infuriating I mean
that's that's the conversation
everyone's going to have with themselves
right now it's like is this is this
working and Trump Trump's strongest
thing has always been immigration and
it's never been something Biden can
handle so real quick just on the other
story about the uh migrants at the
airport I've got some photos sent to me
that are a little bit clearer but
there's just screenshots he is
definitely wearing a brown round yeah
you can clearly see it and his Insignia
in his arm is a Drill Sergeant insignia
it would appear so no idea what that
means but that would imply the this is
not National Guard it could be that he's
just in transit or something but why
would he stop someone from filming
illegal immigrants and why would he be
sitting outside the door in that way and
in his own little rolly chair as well
yeah he's not just sitting in a chair
that happens outside of it just say
maybe he's just uh just traveling and
he's sitting in this random chair has
nothing to do with anything and decided
to stop the guy from filming just
because no idea I mean I could
understand if you thought someone was
filming you being like hey stop but in
this case it doesn't seem like he is
just sort of waiting for a flight it
seems like this is an intentional place
that he is he is lingering now when I'm
in the airport I don't care if people
are filming either so I actually have
had a few situations where you know you
have some Karens come up to you as
you're filming these illegal immigrants
and they'll try and stop you and it's
always hilarious cuz you know my my
cameraman Juan poor Juan he tries to be
nice with them and I just immediately
flip the switch and it's like get out of
my face but I say it a lot more angry
and then they immediately kind of shut
down and the can't like even fathom that
you're telling them to just leave you
alone so I can do my job but if I'm just
a random dude in the airport and I see
somebody filming I'm not going to go up
to you especially if they you're filming
something that's totally unrelated to
you and yeah maybe you're in the
background of it I'm not saying you know
I I learned something
very important about these protesters
from owning a cat so you know you get
these protesters they come up to get in
your face when you're trying to film and
they're just trying to obstruct you and
so whenever my cat comes up to me and is
you know being annoying whatever I
just just blow on them just blow on them
and they go away and there you go and
the protest you start blowing in their
face and stop what are you doing and
they try to hold their hand in front of
your camera or whatever you blow on them
they'll go away actually I'm kidding
don't do that I don't know what the
legality is of blowing on I think you'd
be fine how are you going to prove that
I was blowing on you I was breathing I
was exhaling I took a big breath in you
know a strong exhale enough to feel my
breath on your face you're too close
being filmed you pull the camera out
he's like I'm out if bucko is annoying
you you just pull out the camera and he
immediately goes away yeah but it but in
the video that we saw from De call it's
wild that people are like stop I just
got to say these people are evil look
you go to a trump rally walk out the
camera and you've done it and what
happens they crowd around in excitement
and say o look at me I want to talk
about why I care about America and
here's what I want to do and here's
everything I believe in they have
nothing to hide I stand by these things
yeah and then you go to the left and
they're like quick shut them down people
are going to find out what we're really
up to well just like at protests that
turn into riots they will not allow
filming at all because they know what is
going on is illegal and they want it to
remain hidden so well it's not not just
that it's illegal they know that if the
public finds out what they're doing that
they will lose public support so there's
there's a lot of memes about this but
this is what I experienced with Occupy
Wall Street there's a famous video where
Occupy Wall Street put this video out
and it's a cop swinging his baton
violently at people and they made the
Baton turn into a light saber very smart
and they were like not it was a double
layer scop the idea was a cop attacked
protesters we're going to make fun of
him everyone shared the video so people
start sharing this video of the cop with
the Baton going and they're like hahaa
what they don't show you is the cop got
attacked first by Occupy Wall Street
protesters Riders at that point knocking
down a barricade and then knocking his
head off and shoving him and then he
starts pushing with The Paton then
swings when I'm down there and I'm
filming this and it's raw and live
streamed they're getting pissed off
because now regular people get an
archive of exactly what happened
protester attacked cop cop attacked
protester not cop randomly attacked
protester don't get me wrong cops also
randomly arrest random people too and
lie about it not going to defend them on
that one but in this context yeah
everyone's trying to win some agenda by
controlling the flow of information it's
the Ryan long bit where he's like I take
the footage of the cop attacking the
protester I sell it to CNN I take the
footage of the protester attacking the
cop I sell to Fox yep and the best part
is like once I accidentally sent he said
once I accidentally sent video of
protesters picking up garbage uh to Fox
News they got M said what's this I said
just play in Reverse it looks like
they're
littering that was a good one just play
looks like they're littering yeah that
was a great bit how he can sell the same
footage to both news agencies and you it
really is true though like in my
experience of Licensing footage like you
license certain footage to when I was
independent you license certain news
organizations want to see C like
different things so the violent stuff
you know clearly goes to Fox and the
more right-wing organizations and then
you know the O Rah raw the speeches and
stuff that's what the leftwing
organizations want to see yeah so there
there's a lot of truth behind that yeah
but like if you get a video of a cop
whacking a protester MSNBC is going to
be like name your price you get video of
a protester whacking a cop Fox News says
name your price yep to be fair though
you know I'm being a little bit
hyperbolic Fox is absolutely more fair
that's just of course they want like hey
this is going to do really well on TV so
we want this video where the cop is
being hit or whatever but in my
experience these left lefting
organizations will shut you down in two
seconds if the narrative is outside in
any way and fox will will run whatever
want say a perfect example of that is
after January 6 after I documented the
shooting of Ashley babbit Fox you at
least Laura Ingram they licensed my
video and I went on and actually
appeared and I told them what happened
she wasn't being violent she was
actively trying to deescalate and then
all the left-wing organizations they
scheduled an interview with me after
they licensed my footage and then they
canceled last second and then ran with
their own narrative that was completely
wrong
yep yeah that's how it works I think
that's why people become disenfranchised
with with the media right they see the
same video appear in different places
without context and I think that's what
I find so interesting about the
ecosystem that's appeared I mean you're
definitely a huge part of this of uh
independent journalists or you know
people who start off on just kind of
because they want to know they want to
be on the ground I think Tim is similar
in this respect uh who can tell you well
this is what was going on there and you
are able to connect with them more
directly through YouTube or X or rumble
or whatever uh you are more likely to
believe the person who has built
themselves up than the person who is
just sort of suddenly appearing under
the brand name mainstream media logo and
saying no no don't question anything I
have it right yep hence why mainstream
media is dying rates we've never seen
before and digital media at least
independent digital media is growing at
rates that we've also never seen before
shout out to tenant media so you know
someone super chated too saying basic
Army traines fly into Atlanta's uh uh
drill sergeants picked them up wish
there was more to it but probably not
the state senator said the army guy it's
US Army says took my phone it was a
scrimmage between he and I know to get
the phone back and he proceeded to tell
me to get out of here and made a big big
scene out of it so it's like I don't
know man maybe he's just really Pro
illegal
immigrant loves these people maybe he
was just there to pick up some you know
trainees and then he got asked hey can
you watch this room while you're waiting
and he was like sure I have no idea but
I feel
like I hope this story makes it to
members of Congress who can launch an
inquiry and get someone to testify as to
why this happened ask this state senator
to testify who like and we got to know
what this was about maybe it's just the
army guy of his own valtion was like I
don't like cameras okay
maybe that's the simplest explanation to
me he just didn't want to be filmed but
again we need context as to why this
person was there at all uh or why does
he happen to be in front of this room
full of you know criminal migrant I just
I don't get I like I don't get why so
many things are lining up if he were
just anywhere in the airport I would buy
that it was like I don't like to be
filmed but the fact in front of this
room why would they have a drill
sergeant guarding a room exactly well
you know I don't like to be filmed but
if someone's filming me I'm not going to
assault them on camera to get them to
stop filming me that doesn't seem very
logical weird he's like look I haven't
done my makeup yet I got to just get the
camera off me I don't know but I don't I
don't I I I don't want to believe that
there is a an official order that being
said CBP is actively engaged in human
smuggling m i don't it wouldn't be
surprising at this point it really
wouldn't be with the the roote of
corruption and the roote of cartel and
NGO money flowing around cuz it is a lot
more I mean the the NGO that I was at
with San Antonio PD their Federal
funding I think it went from 10 million
to like 70 million year by year so the
amount that they're getting and then the
amount that they're basically hiding and
straight up laundering is insane and it
grows year by year so this is huge money
for anybody involved dude I think that's
like the big thing that shakes a lot of
people that are like the old school
classic Democrats do is when you tell
them and you to explain how much money
they're getting and how much just going
nowhere this may be a substantially
larger Scandal than we yet realize I
will stress maybe it is a lot of nothing
but we got a Super Chat and this is from
uh let me see here we go uh let's see
which one was I just
reading this this one's big so I want to
make sure I get it
right BQ says Tim to be honest it looks
like a group going to boot camp I was
stuck in an unmarked room at an airport
until my flight was ready however there
were volunteers from a group called team
libertad which boasts helping migrants
travel on social
media I think the piece line up pretty
perfectly that criminal aliens are being
trained to join the armed forces well
there's been a lot of interviews too
where people talk to these uh criminal
aliens that are coming over and they're
like what did you do in your home
country and they straight up say we're
soldiers like that is what we did I mean
you have dozens of these interviews
happening so I would not put it past
them trying to recruit especially the
recruitment numbers being so low if
you're allowing them into the country
illegally why wouldn't you want them to
join the Army you have a room full of
migrants a whistleblower reported to a
state senator Republican state senator
in Georgia who went there and filmed and
saw team libertad in fact you can see
team libertad on his shirt with a lard
an organization which boasts of helping
migrants travel on social media with a
drill sergeant out in front apparently
guarding the room and trying to stop the
guy from filming the most likely
scenario criminal aliens are being
offered join the US Military and they
are heading to training doesn't look
good I don't know that's true I'm not
saying it is I'm saying that seems to be
the most plausible scenario here and
we've predicted this as a possibility
many people have that US military
numbers recruitment numbers are way down
way down people don't want to join up
and they may have found their way to
bolster the numbers could it be the
reason the Costco is selling more food
World War III is potentially on the
horizon Iran uh is about to be Biden's
going to attack Iran and so they're like
we don't know or care where we get them
from we need as many troops as possible
these are going to be low tier guys they
can drop on the front lines but what do
they care man I remember when I was
trying to join the Army out of high
school I had to get my hand tattoo
lasered off because they wouldn't give
me a special waiver and now here we are
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time